good afternoon Paul D Marino holds the
William and Bernice grew [ __ ] chair in
constitutional history at Hillsdale
College and is the director of academic
programs at the college's kirby center
he received his BA from the state
university of new york and his MA and
PhD in history at the university of
maryland in addition to teaching at
Hillsdale for 13 years he has held
visiting professorships at Princeton
University and the University of Paris
School of Law he is the author of black
Americans and organized labor a new
history and the American state from the
Civil wards the New Deal the twilight of
constitutionalism and the triumph of
progressivism forthcoming please join me
in welcoming to the podium dr. Paul
Moreno
Thank You Portia and David for that nice
introduction I'm glad you could all be
here the day after the snow Questor I
just moved out here from Michigan there
was a new amusing the way in which
people responded to the threat of a
couple of inches of snow as David
mentioned I'm a historian and so the
story or a series of stories I want to
tell this afternoon is how the defining
feature of what we call progressivism or
modern liberalism has been the use of
public power to serve private interests
particularly to reduce competition and
to establish cartels simply put a cartel
is an effort by competitors in the same
line of work to agree not to compete as
Adam Smith put it men of the same trade
seldom meet together even for merriment
or diversion but the conversation ends
in a conspiracy against the public or in
some contrivance to raise prices a
familiar cartel example would be OPEC or
oil producers openly set production
quotas in order to maintain and agreed
upon price for their product Major
League Baseball is everyone's favorite
legally sanctioned cartel the New York
Yankees and the Boston Red Sox may
compete on the field but the front
offices are in cahoots this is of course
the most common phenomenon in human
politics it is the problem of faction
that James Madison described in the 10th
Federalist it goes back to the classical
foundations of Western political thought
in Aristotle for example who defined a
true polity or a right Constitution as
one that governs for the good of the
whole and not for a part but in the 20th
century progressives and modern liberals
abandoned the constitutional restraints
that were meant to work against
factional politics instead government
became the propagator and overseer of a
faction based system a Madison is
perversely often credited or accused of
legitimizing faction in the 10th
Federalist but that legitimation came
from the 20th century progressives they
made a virtue of a Madison still
regarded as a vice an inescapable one
but still a vice of Republic's antitrust
law is a good example of this phenomenon
though most people or at least people
who are aware there is such a thing as
NT from
law think that those laws are supposed
to prevent monopolies or cartels these
laws are more often been used to protect
small local monopolies against larger
more efficient competitors the late
Robert Bork did pioneering work in this
field describing American antitrust law
as a policy at war with itself Congress
has never been clear whether the law was
meant to foster competition for the
benefit of consumers or to maximize the
number of competitors for the benefit of
small businesses the Supreme Court
recovered this legislative punt and
rented in a consumer benefit direction
in 1911 it ruled that the first sherman
antitrust act only outlawed unreasonable
combinations in restraint of trade small
business advocates then got Congress to
create the Federal Trade Commission in
1914 which outlawed unfair methods of
competition something more it was hoped
than what earlier antitrust laws had
outlawed small business partisans hoped
that the commission would prevent anyone
from becoming too big rather than
controlling them after they had already
become too big their chief theorist was
louis dee Brandeis the progressive
lawyer who would later join the Supreme
Court Brandeis believed that big
business only came about via unfair and
unethical methods never as a result of
greater efficiency for Brandeis bigness
was like a cancer always the side of
malignancy it harmed shareholders honest
competitors and consumers all at once he
called this the curse of bigness since
Congress was unable to define and
specify the nefarious methods that
produce bigness it left this to an
independent commission the same thing is
happening right now in the dodd-frank
acts creation of a Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau that will prosecute
and punish abusive lending practices and
nobody knows what abusive means Congress
has left the agency to define the
offense that it will then prosecute and
punish but the antitrust laws and the
Federal Trade Commission had little
impact though there have been periods
when the Justice Department the FTC and
the courts had made mergers and
acquisitions more difficult over the
long run they've done little to
influence the industrial structure of
the United States with one notable
exception banking which I'll talk about
in a minute the US looks much like the
rest of the end
fertilize world were a large a sorry a
small number of large firms dominate
certain industries that naturally enjoy
what economists call economies of scale
and other such benefits one interesting
chapter of the antitrust story was its
impact on labor unions labor unions had
long acted like conspiracies in
restraint of trade and were thus the
proper subjects of antitrust law unions
are cartels whose goal is to reduce
output labor and to raise prices wages
their methods strikes and boycotts were
also usually illegal or conducted in
illegal ways in its early years the
antitrust laws were more effective
against labor than against producer
organizations this led the American
Federation of Labor to undertake a
campaign to have unions exempted from
the antitrust laws which had had largely
achieved in the 1930s American banking
policy also illustrates the cartel
promoting phenomenon we hear a lot today
about how federal policy at bet's
financial institutions that are too big
to fail and harm small local or
community banks there's a great deal of
truth in this but it is also true that
historically smaller state banks have
used government power to insulate
themselves from larger out-of-state
competitors this is largely the product
of our peculiar federal system and the
suspicion about federal involvement in
banking that goes back to Jefferson and
Hamilton and the first bank of the
United States it took a very long time
for the u.s. to get any kind of central
bank and although banking today is more
concentrated than ever American banking
is still a lot less concentrated than
most other advanced economies not only
the national policy protects state
banking monopolies but states often
protected County or unit banks by doing
things like outlying branch banking
large banks did their best to end these
restrictions a century and a half ago
New York bankers hope that the national
currency act would give them an
advantage over state banks but even
after Congress taxed to state bank notes
out of existence small state banks
rebounded and outnumbered national banks
by the end of the 19th century a century
ago progresses again led by Louis
Brandeis claimed that a Wall Street
money trust abetted industrial
monopolies but American banking was
actually becoming less centralized
before the
creation of the Federal Reserve System
in 1913 indeed there's considerable
evidence that the big bank creators of
the Fed hope that the new system would
relieve them from small bank competition
that is to say what we call
progressivism was really corporate
liberalism or sometimes called crony
capitalism to some degree the Fed did
help large banks especially after the
Great Depression which hit the financial
industry with another wave of regulation
banks were among the first institutions
at the Hoover administration and the
reconstruction Finance Corporation the
mother of all bailouts considered too
big to fail banking remained very
concentrated and uncompetitive for
several decades after the Depression
when the goals of security and equality
prevailed over those of innovation and
growth these mid-century years were the
ones of greater income equality strong
unions and consistent ory tax rates
which progressives today would like to
return to banking was reduced to what
was called the a simple 363 formula you
borrow at three percent lended six
percent and you're on the golf course at
three o'clock president john f kennedy
promised to get the country moving again
in 1960 and he appointed james j saxon
as controller of the currency who warned
of over-regulation in the banking
industry but significant financial
service deregulation didn't come until
the 1970s and 1980s and concentration
reached a low point around 1990 in an
industry so highly regulated as banking
it's hard to say what level of
concentration would result from the
operation of unfettered market forces
but clearly we see a history that has
veered between a concern with the curse
of bigness and one that has produced
institutions that are too big to fail
many of us are familiar with the fact
that traditional constitutional
limitations on federal power have been
invaded by an expansive definition of
Congress's power to tax and to regulate
commerce among the states it is worthy
of note that the development of these
powers what used to be called a several
police power resulted from the same kind
of anti-competitive cartel lysing that
I've been discussing historians have
shown that a great deal of progressive
legislation that claimed to protect the
people or the little guys against the
interests or big business were in fact
supported by the
interests themselves the Pure Food and
Drugs Act of 1906 arose from attempts to
eliminate competition from new food
products sugar producers condemned the
glucose an artificial sweetener
developed in Napoleonic France straight
whiskey distillers wanted relief from
cheaper blended whiskies have them
defined as adulterated food products
cream of tartar producers sought to
demonize acid base or alum baking
powders the royal baking company for
example denounced alum as a dangerous
drug and pictured phosphate as being
made from old bones covered with vitriol
and it's appealed to mothers to protect
their family's health by using cure
cream of tartar baking powder and they
falsely reported that an entire
Pennsylvania's family had died from
eating bread made with a competitor's
baking powder when margarine or oleo
margarine as it was then called was
invented as a butter substitute in the
1860s American dairy farmers clamored
for suppression of this new rival they
claim that olia was dangerous to health
or that it was colored yellow and
fraudulently sold his butter several
states prohibited its manufacture and
sale all together the New York Court of
Appeal struck down an óleo prohibition
act in 1885 while the state could
certainly enact safeguards against fraud
the court said it cannot absolutely
prohibit óleo to drive the substituted
article from the market and protect
those engaged in the manufacture of
dairy products against the competition
of cheaper substitutes but the US
Supreme Court upheld Pennsylvania's óleo
prohibition Justice John Marshall Harlan
emphasized that every possible
presumption would be given to the
legislature in this exercise of the
police power as such laws were
unnecessarily oppressive the oppressed
must resort to the polls not to the
court justice stephen feel dissented
claiming that the Fourteenth Amendment
protected the natural right to seek and
produce food by which life can be
preserved and enjoyed in all ways not
encroaching upon the equal right of
others he remarked that the Legislature
should have extended congratulations and
reward rather than prohibition to the
manufacturers of this salubrious
foodstuffs he could imagine no greater
invasion of the rights of the citizen
than this óleo prohibition in 1886
Congress enacted an excise tax on
Liam the hearings were described as
little more than a witch hunt in which
óleo opponents claim that it was
manufactured from dead dogs mad dogs and
drown sheep the bills proponents
virtually admitted that it was a piece
of what was then called class
legislation one iowa representative
noted that agrarian states had supported
the tariff though it benefited Eastern
manufacturing states if the
protectionists of the East Stand loyally
by the interests of the farmers the law
of reciprocity will not be forgotten by
the representatives who now ask for
assistance log rolling is very rarely
expressed so openly as it was in this
case the dairy men preferred a ten cent
per pound tax to drive olya out of the
market the Congress enacted a milder two
cent tax and required manufacturers and
sellers to purchase federal licenses and
clearly package and label their product
is olya the Nation magazine then was
very conservative commented that the Act
established the principle that Congress
possesses the power to pass an act
discriminating in favor of one domestic
industry as against another and was a
plain violation of the spirit of the
Constitution President Grover Cleveland
reluctantly signed the bill and what we
today would call a signing statement he
told Congress that if he had been truly
convinced that the revenue act was
really a pretext to destroy one industry
of our people for the protection and
benefit of another he would have vetoed
the bill but the tax established óleo as
a legitimate article of Interstate
Commerce preventing butter States from
stopping imports from óleo states some
states then require dolio to be colored
pink or blue but the Court struck these
acts down Derry interests returned to
Congress for further relief debate in
Congress over a new 1902 óleo tax was
extensis at a time sophisticated many
members were clearly aware of the
constitutional issues at stake
ultimately the view that prevailed was
expressed by Maryland representatives
william h jackson this government sir is
all-powerful he said this government is
the people and the people can do
anything with their government that they
desire this is an age of progress
exactly at this time of the turn of the
century that the progressive movement
began to turn and have this view of the
sovereign power of the federal
government the court upheld the new óleo
tax justice white observe the
Congress's power to enact such an excise
is so completely established as to
require only statement but few
precedents concern the use of a federal
excise to eliminate a product from the
market the clearest parallel example was
the elimination of state bank notes
during the Civil War which wyd admitted
was done under the federal currency
power he further admitted that the
Constitution established limits to the
taxing power attacks he said so extreme
has to be beyond the principles which we
have previously stated not for revenue
but solely for the purpose of destroying
Rights which could not be rightfully
destroyed consistently with the
principles of freedom and justice upon
which the Constitution rests would be
unconstitutional three justices
dissented but unfortunately without
opinion the consumer interest ultimately
prevailed for the law had little impact
on the oleo industry then there are ways
around the attacks the Congress imposed
and though the dairy industry could say
lost this this effort it did establish
taxation as an important basis for an
emerging federal police power it was
later applied to outlaw phosphorus
matches opium and other narcotics the
Great Depression amplified calls for
government relief from economic
competition President Herbert Hoover
himself a progressive though still often
depicted as the last of the lazy fair
reactionaries helped create the
reconstruction Finance Corporation the
RFC was the original bailout program for
businesses that were too big to fail it
resurrected the war finance corporation
of World War one which had only recently
expired the RFC did what the Federal
Reserve Board had failed to do providing
a lender of last resort for banks and
public utilities critics easily derided
the agency as a millionaire's goal
Nebraska progressive George Norris
jeered saying I have been called a
socialist but in the wildest flights of
my imagination I never thought of such a
thing Hoover didn't want to recommend
the agency but early in 1932 it escaped
his political ability to resist it and
the RFC did become notoriously
politicized and corrupt the most
ambitious attempt to cartel lies the
American economy came in the New Deal
period under the National Industrial
Recovery Act of
1933 the Nira was a modified version of
a plan by General Electric president
Gerard swope to suspend the antitrust
laws and allow trade associations to
regulate themselves President Hoover
rejected the plan is the promotion of
price-fixing and gigantic trusts and
called it essentially fascist the
Roosevelt administration accepted its
basic outline though made significant
modifications to it the Act permitted
trade associations to write their own
codes of fair competition for their
industries with the president's approval
and the president could also impose a
code on an industry or limit businesses
to those to whom he issued licenses the
Act did not explicitly permit
price-fixing but it practically invited
it the Act stipulated that the codes are
not designed to promote monopolies or to
eliminate or a press small enterprises
but this is what it ultimately ended up
doing it also provided an important
guarantee that workers could join unions
the Nira reflected the progressive
belief the government could regulate or
limit competition without promoting
monopoly or to put it another way that
it could promote the right kinds of
monopolies small business cartels as
well as cartels for farmers or workers
but not big industrial monopolies
President Roosevelt explained to
Congress that the antitrust laws were
meant to prevent giant monopolies not to
foster cutthroat or or ruinous
competition the Recovery Act represented
a marriage of business price fixing and
labor price fixing United Mine Workers
president john l lewis urged Congress to
give both management and labor a closed
shop socialist party leader Norman
Thomas denounced the act as a complete
denial of the bases bases of the old
capitalism a capitalist syndicalism in
action in essence fascist many Senate
progressives led by william bora opposed
the act Robert Wagner of New York
claimed that there was the only way to
realize the original purpose of the
antitrust laws this act also represented
a colossal delegation of legislative
power to the president won the Congress
was willing to accept Texas
representative Sam Rayburn said it is
very true that under this bill the
president has made a dictator over
industry for the time being but it is a
benign dictatorship for my part I'm
proud to trust him and proud to follow
him Roosevelt aptly called the Nira the
most important and far-reaching
legislation ever enacted by an American
Congress simultaneously the Agricultural
Adjustment Act tried to do the same
thing for farmers allowing them to agree
on production limits that would raise
prices for their crops even to the point
of killing millions of piglets to raise
pork prices and plowing under a third of
the 1933 cotton crop and if you're if
you know anything about foreign policy
that would be another good illustration
of what I'm talking about a program that
was supposed to be about preserving
small farmers most of the benefits end
up going to agribusiness nevertheless
the Nira quickly disappointed the public
and organized labor in particular though
the National Recovery administration the
agency that administered the Act was
commonly depicted as having been
captured by business businesses opposed
its extension and the NRA consistently
supported organized labor the NRA faced
an impossible task of trying to
reconcile irreconcilable policies again
we see a policy at war with itself as
Robert Bork put it to protect small
businesses but not to promote monopoly
to restore employment while promoting
unions and to raise producer prices and
increase consumption at the same time
the Justice Department's antitrust
prosecutions ran into cartel plans
approved by the recovery agency meat
packers on reduced code hours couldn't
slaughter the glut of condemned
Agricultural Adjustment Act piglets
quickly enough in March 1934 Roosevelt
established a natural recovery review
board to investigate complaints Clarence
Darrow headed it and roundly condemned
the administration Roosevelt later
complained that the board proceeded
rather as a prosecuting attorney to
prove a case against business rather
than as an impartial review board and Ra
officials denounced Darrow is the
mouthpiece of chiselers and sweat shop
operators the NRA Nira was so outlandish
that the Supreme Court struck it down
unanimously with even the most liberal
justices on board the administration had
long avoided trying to enforce the act
criminal sanctions because it doubted
its constitutionality now it ended up in
a ridiculous posture defending the
Recovery Act
trivial case the Schechter brothers ran
a small kosher slaughtering business in
Brooklyn and were accused of violating
the live poultry code one charge
involved selling an unfit chicken and to
this day the case Schechter versus the
United States is referred to as the sick
chicken case but even more revealing was
the the codes prohibition of straight
killing were more accurately straight
selling which forbade sellers to allow
customers to choose particular chickens
forcing them to accept whatever fouls
occupied a coop or a half coop again
this is all about protecting producer
rather than consumer interests sustained
laughter punctuated the oral argument as
the justices considered the implications
of such rules Chief Justice Hughes for
unanimous Court invalidated the Nira the
entire Act unconstitutionally delegated
legislative powers to the president who
in turn delegated them to private
interest groups such a delegation of
legislative power is unknown to our law
and is utterly inconsistent with the
constitutional prerogatives and duties
of Congress huge rip the ax applies no
standards for any trade industry or
activity instead of prescribing rules of
conduct it authorizes the making of
codes to prescribe them and again this
was the high point indeed the only point
of what's referred to as the non
delegation doctrine the court had never
before said that an act violated that
principle and it never will again
moreover the sector's business was
entirely intrastate without any
semblance of a direct effect on
Interstate Commerce Hughes noted that
this distinction was essential to the
maintenance of our constitutional system
without it there will be no limits to
Congress his legislative power with
these fatal objections the court did not
need to consider whether the Act also
violated the Due Process Clause even
justice Cardozo concurred saying that
the act was delegation running riot and
one that's written to end our federal
system killing the Nira was especially
gratifying to Justice Brandeis he told
one of the principal drafters of New
Deal legislation this is the end of this
business of centralization and I want
you to go back and tell the president
that we're not going to let this
government centralized everything it's
come to an end the president has been
living in a fool's paradise Brandeis
urged the new dealers to go home back to
the states
is where they must do their work as it
turned out the new dealers would find
plenty of work at both the state and the
national level after FDR threatened to
pack the Supreme Court in 1937 the court
dropped its objections to both federal
and state rent-seeking though the
administration didn't resurrect anything
as comprehensive as the Nira it didn't
act laws to promote cartels in more
targeted industries organized labor for
example got the National Labor Relations
Act coal mining companies in the United
Mine Workers limited production and
raised prices in coal a new agricultural
adjustment act was enacted for growers
of certain commodities the trucking
industry got the motor carrier Act
limiting entry into that industry and
also providing relief for railroads from
trucking competition when the old
Supreme Court had struck down both
federal and state economic restrictions
FDR complained that it created what he
called a no-man's land of anarchical
business depredation now with both the
federal and the States federal
government and the states enjoying an
unfettered police power the no-man's
land had become a zone of concurrent
regulatory power as political scientist
Jane Perry Clark noted in 1938 not all
federal development has been at the
expense of the states for government as
a whole federal state and local has
surged ceaselessly forward it thus
weakened the system of competitive
federalism by which the Constitution
discouraged the seeking of class
legislation and law professor Michael
Griffith has described this in his new
book the upside down Constitution very
very thoroughly it is certainly clear
that the 1930s witnessed an oddity of
class legislation as interest groups
mobilized to take advantage of new
regulatory freedom Louisiana restricted
the issuing of riverboat pilot licenses
to blood relatives of incumbent pilots
Michigan restricted bartending to males
in Colorado criminalized activity that
tended to or had the effect of bringing
into disrepute the state's dry cleaning
price-fixing act in the late 19th
century courts had frustrated the
efforts of plumbers to control entry
into their trade now boards of wallpaper
hangers photographers and watch makers
were able to control entry into their
professions
while some state courts kept the due
process alive in a rearguard action to
preserve Occupational freedom the US
Supreme Court fled the economic field
and adopted a new agenda that of
protecting non property or personal
rights and the rights of what it called
discrete and insular minorities but
commercial or business regulation was
was an open field the last phenomenon
I'd like to discuss is how the Supreme
Court helped to promote local monopoly
power by abandoning its power to fashion
a common law in matters of Interstate
Commerce one of the problems that the
Constitution meant to remedy was
interstate discrimination States sought
to protect their local economies from
outside competition the founders tried
to prevent such vulcanization by a
number of constitutional provisions
including giving the federal courts
jurisdiction in suits between citizens
of different states this is known as
diversity jurisdiction and was meant to
provide out of state defendants with a
neutral federal forum to escape local
bias against them in the Judiciary Act
of 1789 Congress directed the federal
courts to use the laws of the states in
diversity cases but in 1842 in the case
of Swift's versus Tyson the Supreme
Court held that state common law rules
and areas like contracts and torts did
not bind the federal courts which are
free to develop their own rules from
general principles of commercial
jurisprudence the kind of natural law
jurisprudence the federal judiciary thus
greatly facilitated the development of a
nationwide free market by mitigating the
hostility of local businesses and juries
Congress supported this movement and
expanded the federal courts diversity
jurisdiction throughout the 19th century
complaints soon arose now especially in
the less industrialized South in the
West that the federal courts had given
northeastern corporations a privileged
position the populace and then the
progressives called for redressing or
eliminating federal diversity
jurisdiction they cited cases like
Baltimore and Ohio Railroad against ball
in 1893 in which the Supreme Court
overturned Ohio's more plaintiff
friendly standard in industrial accident
cases and held that injured workers
could not recover if their fellow
servants had contributed to the accident
but
decisions like this were exceptional
well the progress is depicted them as
being the the rule indeed federal courts
sometimes use more plaintiff friendly
rules than state courts but progressives
like Felix Frankfurter persisted in
claiming that federal diversity
jurisdiction had been mischievous in its
consequences he said baffling in this
application and untenable in theory and
contrary to the intent of the framers of
the Constitution and the first Judiciary
Act behind the scenes progressive legal
academics hope to use tort litigation as
a means of economic redistribution they
wanted the courts to devise a system of
social insurance using the more powerful
and wealthy corporations to subsidize
the weak and poor through lawsuits the
ethics of the legal profession turned
from shunning to celebrating
ambulance-chasing the change came
suddenly and unexpectedly in 1938 in an
opinion by Justice Brandeis the darling
of the progressives who Woodrow Wilson
had put on the court Brandeis argued
that swift the doctrine of federal
common law had produced mischievous
results and grave discrimination by
non-citizens or large out-of-state
corporations against citizens small
local interests the doctrine though
followed for the last 96 years was not
only misguided he said but
unconstitutional this being the only
time the court has declared one of its
own decisions unconstitutional Brandeis
and the progressives had accused
corporations of what's known as forum
shopping moving their cases two more
defendant friendly federal courts but
his decision encouraged forum shopping
by plaintiffs keeping their cases in
jurisdictions more likely to award large
damage judgments against big business
the Supreme Court also adopted a new set
of rules of civil procedure in 1938
which made it easier for plaintiffs to
bring suit in federal court and to turn
the pretrial discovery process into a
fishing expedition in the ensuing
decades plaintiff lawyers came to depict
them cells as Crusaders for social
justice using the lawsuit to promote
equality and to vindicate the rights of
the poor and women and minorities and
consumers against irresponsible
corporations indeed tort plaintiffs they
said acted like private attorney
generals achieving public good through
their private lawsuits lawyers began to
add
verte eyes and to bring mass tort
class-action suits against manufacturers
of asbestos and silicon breast implants
and ultimately the tobacco industry thus
the legal system contributed to a social
and cultural movement that devalued
individual responsibility blame society
for all problems and focus on victimhood
by the 1980s it was increasingly
apparent that the litigation system had
gotten out of control stories about
rageous lawsuits abounded the most
famous was the story of the woman who
sued McDonald's after she spilled hot
coffee on herself others included a
woman who won a 1.6 million dollar
judgment against the phonebook company
that had led her to a physician who
botched her liposuction surgery another
was a student who sued his school for
stress caused by summer homework and a
city employee who backed his dump truck
into his own car and then sued the city
such suits provided material for
innumerable lawyer jokes among late
night TV comics and talk radio hosts the
economic effects of the litigation
explosion were significant litigation
costs grew at four times the rate of the
economy since 1930 amounting to two
percent of the national income average
court awards in Cook County in Chicago
rose in inflation-adjusted terms from 52
thousand dollars to 1.2 million dollars
between 1960 in 1984 by 1990 it was
estimated that tort law system cost the
country three hundred billion dollars a
year the plaintiff bar took in forty
billion dollars in 2002 plaintiffs
themselves netted only about half of
that amount of judgments after paying
lawyers fees and other costs the
indirect cost of increased liability
raised prices for everyone and thus
inhibited innovation and economic growth
as a West Virginia Supreme Court justice
put it much of my time is devoted to
ways in two ways to make business pay
for everyone else's badlock American law
had originally tried to compensate
injured victims to restore them to their
condition before the injury while also
deterring bad and irresponsible behavior
by not rewarding the negligent Oliver
Wendell Holmes jr. put it in his 1881
classic the common law the general
principle of our law is that loss from
accident must lie where it falls as
another observer put it ideally nobody
would be liable to anyone for
anything since nineteen thirty-eight we
replaced that with a system in which
everyone is liable to everyone for
everything we this is again typical of
the way that the progresses have
reshaped American law in the policy in
the private law sector that we started
out forming governments to get us out of
the state of nature the war of every man
against every man as Hobbes put it but
what I've been describing over the past
century our state builders have brought
us back into that state of nature and I
think the private litigation system is a
good illustration of that so let me
conclude there and ask if you any
questions Elliot we're lawyers sort of
our men-at-arms for hire and courts are
just ways to bludgeon your enemies what
what sort of ideas historically have
been have been suggested and what do you
think has some constitutional merit to
be able to move back toward that
constitutionalism well I think one of
the most important a lot of the
important safeguards that prevented this
were a sort of internal social cultural
and even religious in ways that I think
the founders of the Constitution is John
Adams but our Constitution is only going
to work for a particular kind of people
unless there is some sort of social
capital some degree of a virtue in the
people the Constitution is going to be
enough to prevent this sort of thing so
that when the constitutional
restrictions began to break down at the
same time that those moral social
cultural limitations also began to give
way they had a mutually reinforcing
effect the question is always in my
field of legal or constitutional history
is you know that doodoo laws make
culture or this law simply the
reflection of the culture well their
reciprocal and they're reinforcing
and what I don't think you see now is
that when people begin to see that
everyone's doing it right the stigma
against certain kinds of behavior erodes
to the point where you no longer have
that that internal individual resistance
who wants to be the last person who's
actually let's say honest and the way
they fill out their income taxes right
the income tax system is just so
perverse that again it practically
encourages otherwise honest and decent
people to do things that arguably they
know our kind of kind of dishonest and
the system has I think this this
tendency of rewarding bad behavior how
do you turn that around is both
institutionally both formal means but
also in a way I pray about this yes sir
do you think that Adams would today
think we have the term the term you use
social capital do you think he would say
that we were the type of people that can
maintain a democracy not to put you on
the spot or anything but no I don't
think he would and in fact many that
many of the framers themselves it wasn't
it was even in their own lifetimes that
they began to doubt whether the
experiment that they had launched could
succeed by the time that they died maybe
the founders believed that you know this
was not going to work out that America
had become to sort of too obsessed with
with equality by the time of the
Jacksonian many of them began to despair
for the whole system John Marshall did
jefferson apparently the only founder
who died just as optimistic as he had
been through his whole life so Adams
himself I think would have been a
doubtful on the other hand his son ended
up becoming part of the system and
President himself and I think the next
generation believed that they could
redeem this is I think Lincoln's a good
example of that right in seeing
especially the way in which avarice and
the lust for power that he saw in the
system of slavery didn't despair but
rather believe that within the
Constitution there was a way of turning
things around and it was was able to do
so sir
so you're not an economist you are
historian but I will ask a question
about economics anyway how how do you
what do you think he explains the higher
rates of gdp growth from the mid 1930s
to the mid-1970s in the slower rates of
gdp growth since the nineteen mid-1970s
oh well actually there are some if you
look at the rates of economic growth in
the post new deal period right the 1950s
for example are usually seen as a period
of great prosperity this is the period
of great expansion of the American
middle class and suburbanization and
sort of flowering of a consumer culture
and all that economic growth in the 50
was actually slow less by historical
standards then had been before the New
Deal this so there was a it was
widespread the prosperity of the 1950s
but the actual overall economic growth
was was was slow I think there's
difference before and after 1913 when
you have the adoption of the Fed and a
lot of these other economic changes so
the hundred years before 1913 the rate
of economic growth was so they have
three point five percent and since then
it's been three point two percent right
and most of all so what now what
difference does that make just you know
three tensile well actually if you run
that over over the period of time we're
talking about a century it means that we
again because of the mathematics
involved that we would be two or four
times better off if we had maintained
the higher rate of economic growth so I
think what you had since the New Deal or
from the 1930s until about nineteen in
the 1970s things began to change you got
more income inequality and sort of more
economic growth in the after the 1970s
and into the 1980s but that period sort
of the New Deal years were one in which
the principal goals were not growth but
stability not entrepreneurship but
security you know again the
in which large sort of slow-moving
organizations dominated the the American
economy that's again the description i
gave of the banking industry is one in
which you know banking was not one for
sort of buccaneering you know sort of
swashbuckling risk-taking entrepreneurs
but rather was about being really
careful and conservative a lot of big
American economic organizations were
like that I think they're also another
factor in this what made that possible
for at least as long as we had it was
World War two and the fact that we are
and principal economic competitors the
Germans and Japanese were you know in
ashes and we enjoyed a period of
insulation from foreign competition that
was the only thing that made this whole
whole thing possible right American auto
makers could afford to give a higher
wages and benefits the United Auto
Workers they would just pass the cost of
those on to the American consumer and
what choice did the American consumer
had you can buy a Japanese car in the
1950s when that being had a change in
the late 60s and early 70s I think that
factor of global competition more than
anything else you know made this the old
the New Deal model impossible so just
those two points or that if you look at
the growth rates in the New Deal period
they're really not there historically
lower not higher and that's because the
the concern was about redistribution and
security rather than rather than growth
I mean these are questions I suppose for
in terms of cervix and philosophy is
labor unions are a good example of this
somebody mentioned before Elliott you
mentioned sort of the Hobbesian system
where everyone seems to be trying to fix
this system so that they can get
something at somebody else's expense but
you are actually yourself worse off from
that system right for a long time
advocates of organized labor said unions
are good for all workers even the
unorganized well most people don't even
make that argument anymore because it's
it's it's untenable but even the
argument that union workers are
themselves better off because of
pro-union laws turns out not to be true
either like economists have made the
argument that everyone's worse off and
even members of labor unions are worth
worse off
because of the macro effect that unions
have on the economy right so I think
that's what a lot of this is uh this
comes down to even if you if you
yourself are better off under this
system you think you're actually worse
off because we all suffer all pay the
costs of this system of again of
rent-seeking and of trying to use
government power to promote our private
interests turn one of the important
antitrust disputes that we never hear
anything about anymore is was an
argument that Theodore Roosevelt had
with his former vice president that as I
understand it he uses the excuse for
running against him and handing the
Republic over ultimately to Woodrow
Wilson can you what what what that was
and whether you think that was his real
the truth about his motivation in
destroying the Republic by allowing
would elicit you Roosevelt and Taft at
Taft yeah well yeah but Roosevelt
running Theodore Roosevelt aft and there
the election to Woodrow Wilson right and
the case the instant case was the US
Steel acquisition of Tennessee coal and
iron in 1907 and the fourth the book
that I have coming out soon I do call
attention to that and say that was one
of the factors that led to the break-up
between taft and roosevelt who had been
you know great friends very very
intimate friends before going into the
nineteen twelve election and it's an
amazing story that had never heard
before very recently but there was a
financial panic another one of these
bank meltdowns in 1907 and one of these
brokerage houses in New York owned a lot
of stock and the Tennessee coal and iron
company and if the in order to save that
bank and to sort of restore the
financial system Roosevelt approved the
acquisition of Tennessee coal and iron
by us deal right US Steel was the
biggest steel producer in United States
and they were very careful about
acquiring other companies
because they were afraid of being
prosecuted under the antitrust laws so
Roosevelt pretty much doesn't don't
worry about it I promise we won't go
after you for for this acquisition and
they picked up Tennessee coal and iron
for a price that again historians have
had disputed this but it was the bargain
of the century you know they paid
something like you know 40 million
dollars for a company that was worth you
know four hundred million dollars or
something like that then when task
became president he instituted the suit
that Roosevelt said that he wouldn't
pursue and that was one of the maid
roses that look bad and half didn't
handle it very well and that was one of
the things that led to the led to the
breakup between all then that suit was
continued through the Wilson
administration ultimately US Steel
prevail they were found not guilty in
1919 but that was one of the reasons for
their that that great friendship
breaking up the political consequences
being as you said splitting the
Republican Party and getting Woodrow
Wilson elected president but the really
interesting thing is that it Wilson went
into office claiming that rows of this
is sort of typical the way in which
Roosevelt was actually in favor of big
business and just wanted to manage them
and regulate them once they had become
big Wilson again Brandeis was sort of
his as chief a mentor about this because
Wilson hadn't thought very much about
these economic issues before he became
president was that we want to prevent
business from becoming big in the first
place it's really not an antitrust
policy so much as it what brand is
called it was you don't want a regularly
big business you want to regularly
competition so that you don't produce
bigness in the first place and that was
the chief issue between the two
candidates in 1912 but because the basic
point was Wilson and Brandeis didn't
know what they were talking about
economically they had this skin sort of
19th century idea that if business is
big it must be because they're doing
something bad right no that's very sort
of popular feeling some people think
well if Bill Gates has 40 billion
dollars nobody can get 40 billion
dollars honestly right he must be doing
something something wrong so this kind
of suspicion that his people had about
bigness that there must be something
wrong with it was big that was the idea
that these guys still had and it took a
long time before
historians I think learn the lessons of
economists that that wasn't the reason
why business becomes big that there are
certain in certain industries there are
our reasons why you're going to have a
small number of large producers right is
this not going to be possible to have
you know a highly decentralized auto
manufacturing industry right automobile
repair on the other hand you're going to
have a large number of small competitors
right try as you might write you could
monopolize the cigarette manufacturing
industry as the Dukes did right people
tried really hard to monopolize or
centralized a cigar manufacturing
business but it just it just didn't work
right Tom McCraw I think he just passed
away although they obviously still alive
and well historian at Harvard has
written a lot about about this about
sort of the economics of regulation that
makes make these points
sir just had a question about you know
Thomas Paine made some comments in his
pamphlet common sense about the factions
and I wondered if you come in that NAT
please ah Tom Paine in common sense that
faction I don't I don't recall that ya
know it seems to me in fact we did had a
relatively decentralized automobile
manufacturing in the 20s and what comes
automobile manufacturers you know from
this all up into the Midwest and upstate
New York and and by the i guess 50s they
were down to two or three or four but
what led to that centralization of the
automobile industry well again people
come up with more efficient ways of
producing automobiles that require a
larger capital to to get the business
started so yeah most industries start
out with a large number of competitors
and then there's a shakeout as the more
efficient more innovative ones again if
there are certain sort of economic
factors that dry if there is again
economies of scale and scope and things
like this large expensive managerial
things being necessary that make it very
expensive to produce the first car right
but then once you produce the first car
to produce the billionth car is very
little you know on the margin in some
industries like that oil refining
automobile manufacturing steel making
things like that at certain most of this
is driven by sort of technological
change you're going to end up with a
unless you do something to artificial
unless you use the power of the
government to try to maintain a larger
number of producers and a lot of times
Americans have have done that you you'll
end up with that kind of structure
because you see it it's the same in
Japan it's the same in Germany it's the
same you know again if you're able to
factor out the political
distortions in this you end up with a
similar kind of industrial structure at
a given level of technology all over the
world but buzzes I've been trying to say
in this talk we've done both we've tried
on the one they're having government
policies that have abetted industries
becoming more concentrated than they
otherwise would be and I think that's
what dodd-frank is doing right now to
the banking industry but historically
we've also done the opposite and
government policy has as often as not I
tried to prevent efficient businesses
from becoming a bigger that was the big
and the big issue in antitrust and the
reason why American antitrust law didn't
work or the way that a lot of its
advocates wanted to was that ultimately
most businesses get bigger because
they're more efficient and the consumer
benefits from that and as much as the
American people are don't like bigness
right and a suspicious of it they
realize that ultimately they're better
off as consumers because of it this is
my Brandeis is such an interesting
figure Brandeis was opposed to bigness
for all these reasons Brandeis was also
opposed to what we again today would
call a consumer economy if you were to
tell Brenda swell actually did these
businesses are actually bigger because
they're more efficient he would have
said well so much the worse than because
then they're just giving people more
stuff that they shouldn't have anyway
hey Dobbs raisin bread brand is such a
fascinating figure he had this idea sort
of a really classical view that the good
life was really Spartan and Brandeis was
himself you know sort of a famous for
his you know he he didn't he didn't
approve spectator sports you know he was
really sort of thrifty and opposed to
luxury in a way that sort of classical
political thinkers were right that
virtue requires a kind of sacrificing
yourself for the public good and not he
didn't like the way that America was
developing and again towards a sort of
consumer society today so if you think
that people are better off if they have
more stuff at lower prices than what I'm
saying makes sense but there are people
who don't like that not many
but a few people who are still still
like that sure I'm kind of broader
perspective if I could argue that we're
in almost a post constitutional era some
large percentage of the people
surrounding this building have no clue
of the history you just addressed who
what differences the Constitution make
written a couple hundred years ago how
and we're better and brighter and more
educated today and so we can usher in a
brave new world however we designed that
how are you attempting or as Hillsdale
or other folks attempting to address
that to help that kind of person
understand why the things that you
discuss today are important and to
understand why the Constitution and how
the country was formed and so on and so
forth is important when so much of the
population one has no clue and they
certainly don't believe it mmhmm yeah
there is a way in which if you say well
we've depart you could make the argument
we departed so much from the principles
of the Constitution that even the effort
to restore some traditional
constitutional principles might do more
harm than good right again I'm thinking
Michael grivas book the upside down
Constitution whereas conservatives like
the principle of federalism for example
right and the idea of restoring power to
the states is considered a conservative
position right it's liberals for the
centralizers conservatives are in favor
of but you know it used to be called
states rights and grievous point is that
well actually the states are as bad as
the federal government some ways they're
worse than the federal government and
they have all what we see in the 20th
century is the state's seem to be
conceding more and more power to the
federal government against their own
interests right why would the state
legislatures have ratified the 17th
amendment and removed from themselves
the power to to choose the Senators
right that seems like a remarkable act
of self-abnegation why would they
approve the income tax amendment to give
the federal government this the
principal source of revenue to increase
its powers and grivas argument is
because the states recognized that even
a stronger federal government would
enhance their ability to engage in this
kind of behavior and that's something
that up until very recently had never
had never occurred to me and
just change the whole way that I thought
that federalism so I think that for my
own bailiwick anyway of history is sort
of to provide the sort of the
alternative examples to show the way and
well how we got to where we are today
and the question of whether as a matter
of fact behind whatever is left of the
formal Constitution the way the system
actually operates today a work that a
lot of my colleagues are doing in
development of the the administrative
state for instance it's good to study
the Constitution and understand the way
that the framers actually thought you
know the system is going to work in the
way that it did work for a long time but
we also have to recognize that for a
couple of decades now what my students
and my children still look at on paper
as the constitutional structure really
is kind of beside the point instead it
is this enormous delegation of powers by
Congress to these bureaucracies these
administrative agencies and they're the
ones who actually make the laws and run
the country again grievin calls the
upside down Constitution was required to
federalism we have completely inverted
the way the framers of the Constitution
thought the system would work and that
could go as well for the separation of
powers and a lot of other constitutional
principles we have time for one more
yes hi the purpose of dodd-frank was to
prevent systemic failure yeah and yet it
seems to me maybe you comment on this
that it will actually do the inverse
because you have more concentration of
larger banks because those are too big
to fail and at the same time the small
or mid-sized banks have to get warm to
incredibly complex set of restrictions
and regulations and I'm just wondering I
don't know where to go what I think what
the question is in that there's a
statement but they pass it well what
were ya can what what if anything can be
done to fix the situation at least
intellectually if not you know can't be
done politically right at this point
yeah the and it's getting history
banking regulation that's the story over
and over again and I say well the said
is supposed to prevent the original
Federal Reserve Act of 1913 panics and
meltdowns and we got one after world war
one and the big one we got in 1929
Herbert Hoover didn't come to this point
de leur late in the campaign but he did
say yet he said don't forget by the way
the Fed was a democratic you know
creation Woodrow Wilson and his friends
right and the Fed and then I think a lot
of it is still very much disputed but a
lot of economist would say the Fed was
responsible for the severity and the the
length of the Great Depression and the
result was that in 1935 the said was
given even more power by Congress so the
story over and over again is you know
nothing succeeds like failure in terms
of bank regulation policy you know screw
the system up you're gonna get more
power and that happens over and over
again in regulation and standing evans a
journalist he'd just forget the name
that he gave to this the syndrome of you
know regulatory failure ends up being
the cause of more regulation right
another economist and deepak allow calls
it the deer is yeast dogma dirige yzma
being the french term for this idea of
government managing and regulating the
economy that there's a problem
government does something to solve the
problem may
is it worse and that becomes the reason
for further government intervention so
yeah how you reverse or get out of that
that that cycle is very difficult to say
was it the original Constitution was
meant to do that one of the things that
the Constitution was meant to do was to
limit the ability of the states by
establishing this federal system right
the Commerce Clause for its first
hundred years would be a great
illustration of that it wasn't that
Congress was regulating the economy
through using the commerce power that it
had Congress did almost nothing rather
it was the courts who use the commerce
power to prevent the states from
interfering in interstate commerce right
so one of the great things that the
Constitution did was to prevent the
states from to minimize this kind of
behavior that I've been talking about
now today I would be very hesitant to
say well we need some kind of
international organization to take care
of the Nash what has now become a
national problem but you know there was
a moment when the Constitution was
formed that you were able to institute
some structural features to to reverse
this process and to actually provide for
and economic improvement in growth so I
don't have any answers okay I mean I
is that this is as a hit as a historian
we can't say much about the future and
usually ask a story you know how do you
get to where you're going the first
thing is going to say it was I wouldn't
start from here it is well think it
explains how you got here not how are
you gonna get